CTIMF THE CRIME
SOMENSWERED ES" END UPN
115 MUTESFTERHEY ARE
IC SLWELL SPOTTED HANNG
WI MTS A MANTE PRE
>> Aley:ERE WH REAION
BECAUSE IS I AMANGOE.INT TGET HT
HE BLAST THE.O.P FOR
PROLGINGHE PANMIC.
HE SAIDASE E021ND THE
PANDIC, U SHLD KNOF
THES REPUBLIN LRS, YOU
VATION CANLED.
YOUR KIDSACK  VIRTU
ARNI AND BK TO MASEVYWHE.
FOR AME,OO NO FURER TN
OBVIOUSLI DOT THK ME O
ANYONELSE CES W GOE
NEW RK, LIFORNIAAND EN WN A MIIG
IT I LEOT OYONE-AF,
B.
NOTISACATIONR A'SACION
CATI.
E ONLY TNG IILL VE
ERIC SWAELL EDITORS HE
COVED HIEE IN THEHOTO.
UNKEOCIRTB BOYIEND OR
FIAN WHOS TOLL THE G
WHTRIMS HITOENLS NT TYOON TLA.A!
TH IS WHY W HEO BIHEN
ITOMES TO PLICEAH
ITIATIVE ASHY.
ARE LLOWING EMSEES.HEM
AND  A KNOW TH.
EARLY I THEORNI, BU I WIL
ORIDE
TIME HEOTAUGHAS CNESE
SP.>> IASOING TO G TRE IAFFENT .
TodHIS GAS LHTINASEY RD THTWEEH
A CHISE S THI HAPPENE
THINGS HAND THEEMOCRATSRE
DOING ONG TH RUBCANSITSAS LHTIN
HALLF FA,ORTF KE
M ADYF IT?
YOU ALE NOINHISOMENT
M BRADY  IT COM I DON'TKNOW IHES
TWEE ALO T WAYITH
SLIGINSO I DON WAN
QTEAK HIMOM BDY, BUT
.
ITS AMANG, TOD TT ISWH THEAREOIW
TH ARESING TS A A
CUURALARSSUE
EY KW TH D'T HAV
SOLUONSOR T PANDEMI
JOBIDESAIDHEN HE W
RUING WAS NNININ AUD
SHOULDOTERESINT.D UM
T DEITE HERITINGHREE
VACCES,HE PROBL IS WTTHEYIVOTEDT
BLICEALT
ITS CUURE WAR BLANG T
OTR G.
AT IS WH THE AREOWN TO
NO
OH WE WOULHAVEOLVE IT, BUT
E OTR GU W AN'TAKING
E VAINES- I VACNATED,
YOARACCITED.
GETTG THEIRUS STL
TH'S T RIDULS PA OF
IS WLEHI BUTHEY N'T
HAVE A ANSR TOT SO MING
SE C YOU DOUT HOWNOAT
FLORA?
AREIVININHEEATH OF
AM
>>odd:HEYRE FUNDERING
WE HE5ECON LEFT.
CDCOAST F AEW CID
IDANCEFTER 180HIPLH FR
EVIOUS RUL, JMYWHAT
KID XED SIGNS LI THI
YEAH --LAUGER]
IT IS SANENODY CANOLLO TS!
THEY RETETEDHEIC FMI
E KEY KEY.TOUT YR RIGHT L IN AUT
YOURIGHTEGUT.
NOBO ISOLWINGHAT.
QUIC TOD TT O LNEY O
NES ISEHERE SLING
SURAE.
YOU LL GET1 MILLIOIF YGEA BLK ET
FOURTH OJULYITHTAMPE
WILLEPHTS WH ONEABY
ZEBRAPPE THE IS YOO
CH FE PRT IS WT I'M
TRYI TOAY, CDC
CARTN.MHINGASYO UNDSTANLI THE DU
AUGHR]
Ashy: IEELIKEHEDC
HA BN UNRSTANDAB WIT THE
IDAN A